très jolie
ravissant cela s'annonce très bien
ah bonjour je ne voudrais pas vu oui
regardez je suis brocanteurs
comment vous ne savez pas ce que c'est
qu'un brocanteur et bien voilà un
brocanteur c'est quelqu'un qui achète et
qui revendent des vieux objets oui
aujourd'hui moi je n'achète que des
vieux objets métalliques 1 vous m'avez
apporté non on va bien sûr vous vous
n'étiez pas au courant j'ai décidé ça ce
matin mais il faut que je vous dise je
ne suis pas un vrai brocanteurs non non
je réunis tous ces objets en métal pour
faire une surprise aux enfants de l'île
à
françois julie sont allés dans leurs
greniers me chercher des objets je rends
françois qui revient déjà est prend soin
des personnes voilà qui est mieux que
c'est pas la peine de crier comme ça moi
je peux pas aller plus vite j'ai cru
pour la moitié du chemin la moitié
seulement qui aura dû courir tout le
long pour qu'elles signalent vraiment tu
exagères je fais tout ce que je peux
pour te faire plaisir du jeu mais compte
aussi c'est vrai excuse moi mais je suis
tellement pressé de voir toutes ces
merveilles à ces merveilles le
merveilleux peut être un grand mot enfin
j'ai réuni des objets qui j'espère te
seront utiles voilà une casserole ou la
pose là voilà voilà deux très jolis
coups hier oui
voilà une boîte de petits pois vivre à
tout tu es sûr que ce sont des petits
points à bout j'en sais rien moi j'ai je
dis ça comme ça pourquoi c'est important
ça n'a aucune importance
elle va parfait et voici enfin une
cuillère à salade ah non ça ne va pas
pourquoi ça ne va pas parce que cette
cuillère est en bois et oui alors j'ai
bien demandé des objets métalliques à
casimir j'avais complètement oublié que
je ne voulais que des objets métalliques
je la garde ça ne fait rien
[Musique]
attends je vais t'aider jeune
danois sa toile
[Musique]
mais toute l'île mais tu n'as pas trouvé
des fumoirs annoncé la société par
contre tu as une bouilloire je viens
d'une passoire c'est parfait au
magnifique cache-pot attendant c'est pas
fini pour tous regarde ta couleur de
peau qu'est ce que c'est que ça symbole
je vois que c'est un bol mais il est
qu'en matière plage qui fait oui en
matière plastique alors excusez-moi
casimir j'avais complètement
c'est que c'est me revoilà le facteur
qui arrive au plus au site apporte
beaucoup d'objets qui lui ai dit de
venir c'est vraiment dur c'est
formidable c'est extraordinaire parce
que aujourd'hui vous avez tous décidé de
me faire plaisir a aujourd'hui tout le
temps casimir vraiment tu exagères
bonjour les amis bonjour fac bojan
secteur alors fichtre casimir jeu je
vois que tu as déjà pas mal d'objets
j'espère en tout cas que collet mien
tous seront utiles mais pourra sur
factor états unis tu te toujours vous
m'avez bien dire que ce n'était pas vrai
après tout être tu n'es pas un méchant
garçon
oublier d'y apporter un calendrier à je
n'aurais pas contre calendrier mais
enfin casimir ceci c'est un très beau
calendrier de l'année dernière d'accord
je tenais à apporter regarde oui mais
malheureusement il est en papier et en
carton
mais oui casimir tu en réseau mais il
pourquoi mais pourquoi mais regardez
vous savez lire lisez la pancarte à la
wii est changée tous vos vieux objets
métalliques
tu as raison quasi nature à raison que
je conserve mon calendrier c'est vrai le
papier le carton ça n'a jamais été du
métal ne soyez pas lui effectué en moi
j'ai fait la même erreur avec une
cuillère à salade en bois à
avec un bol en place et oui et moi je
crois que vous n'êtes pas très
intelligent mais que jumeaux sont dûment
été discrets ils monteront d'accord on a
oublié que le bois la matière plastique
le carton ne sont pas des métaux comme
comme le fait r l'acier le cuivre
l'aluminium etc etc
mais casimir ont fait contre quoi quant
aux tué échangé tout les objets
métalliques laraoui je voulais échanger
contre des billets tu es bien voilà pour
les spectacles merci voilà oui c'est que
c'est bien c'est une offre surprise a
surpris
[Musique]
oui oui
vous voilà dépêchez vous nous ne sommes
pas en retard ça va venir l'avancé non
non non j'avais boutiques et la casim il
se passer à vous les approchez asseyez
vous sur le banc
mais qu'est ce que c'est que c'est pour
sûr je ne comprends rien mais
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs le
grand compositeur casimir à vous
interprétez on va vous improviser une
oeuvre qui s'appelle si les vaches on
dit dans les canards ben non pas
[Musique]